These are safe rooms.
We can put a person with of tuberculosis in it
and he is not
or she is not going to infect
anyone else as long as they are wearing a mask
whereas right now, in every hospital that ever
seen
in a really poor setting
TB patients who are in the hospital
are at great risk of infecting other patients
and at an even greater risk of infecting
health workers who were there all the time.
Hind is just extraordinary person you know
she's originally from Sudan
she's probably now seen as many or more patients
than any clinician
on the face of the earth
dealing with MDR-TB, XDR-TB and HIV.
"and we are trying actually, we
cannot just keep the patient as we
are keeping him in the prison
so we take him outside
so he can go
and during the day, they really need to go
outside and have some fresh air.
So they are very advanced patients
they are HIV positive
with very low CD-4
some of them had CD-4,6, and 11, and as well as CD
side effects for MDR-TB treatment
so we are keeping them for a long time,
but usually they would stay here for 2- 3 weeks maximum."
"So we explain to him that the drug will take up to what,
2 weeks
to pick up, so he has to just relax and allow them to work."
I'm a Doris Duke Fellow so it's a year of clinical research and
I'm working on a community treatment program for MDR-TB
and as part of that we've come here to see
how Partners in Health
have been running their program
This is the map of patient distribution across Lesotho
as you can see the patients are everywhere.
The introduction of Tb treatment
had started in the lowlands before the highlands.
So it is just in the last years
that the TB medications
had been distributed to the clinics in the highlands
but we have seen patients with confirmed MDR
and as well with XDR
from the mountain area
from our clinic in Ohana
had 4 cases with MDR
one of
and another patient with XDR.
In southern Africa
with the combination of HIV and MDR-TB
and patients being so sick and no hospital
being able to do it
what is happening by default in other
countries, even in South Africa,
especially in places like Swaziland and Botswana
is they go into a big hospital with everyone
else
and with very high rates of HIV in the general
population
lots of people were getting infected so this is
you know this is going to have to happen everywhere
in southern African Africa where this is
this kind of problem
the first thing you want to do is get them
healthier
smear negative and then get them out.